the Pentagon working to recover debris and solve
unanswered questions after a U.S fighter jet shot
down a flying object for the second time in a week
President Biden ordered the military to take down
the unidentified object hovering over the remote
and Frozen northern coast of Alaska on Friday the
White House says the object posed a reasonable
threat to the safety of Civilian flights but the
device's origin remains unknown this morning the
twin downings have led to heightened concerns over
China's vast surveillance program and lawmakers
are still pressing the Biden Administration for
answers on the military's response Christina
raffini is at the White House with the very
latest Christina good morning good morning
Michelle the White House says President Biden
ordered this latest shoot down on the advice of
the Pentagon and out of an abundance of caution
but they're still not sure exactly what
this object was and if it posed a threat
we're calling this an object because that's
the best description we have right now the
unidentified floating object roughly the size
of a small car was shot down by fighter jets
over the icy waters of Alaska the White
House says whatever it was was flying at
a height of about forty thousand feet over the
state's northern coast and posed a reasonable
threat to the safety of Civilian flight and
it came in inside our territorial Waters
those Waters right now are frozen but inside
territorial airspace and over territory Waters
a recovery effort is now underway to retrieve
the wreckage but it comes less than a week after
the military shot down a massive Chinese spy
balloon that floated over several States for
seven days before the military shot it down over
the Waters of South Carolina what is concerning
um is that it was yet another unidentified object
violating U.S sovereignty Alaska's senior senator
Republican Lisa murkowski any aspect of U.S
Sovereign territory that is is encroached upon
there's going to be consequences to it Alaska's
Junior Senator Republican Dan Sullivan says the
latest incidents highlight the need for the
U.S to invest in better detection systems
whether the threat is a slow-moving balloon
or an intercontinental ballistic missile our
um Homeland defense needs an upgrade in all
those areas and I think this is a wake-up call
but former Secretary of Defense Mark esper told
CBS the quick action might be evidence the U.S has
already taken some of those steps maybe today's
demonstration of uh closing the Gap and shooting
down this unidentified object is evidence of that
but there's clearly work needs to be done in terms
of addressing the Aerospace picture that we see
still he said it's too soon to know if this latest
object really posed a threat this may end up
being some type of weather balloon or scientific
experiment or or climate research who knows but
I think we need to withhold some judgment first
and yesterday the treasury Department announced
export controls on six Chinese companies they
say are involved in manufacturing or manufacturing
the parts for these type of surveillance balloons
and the U.S says these balloons have been
floated over 40 countries around the world guys
all right Christina thank you